[Aplausos]
[Música]
os voy a hacer una pregunta qué
ideología tiene Vladimir Putin es de
izquierdas o es de derechas en el vídeo
de hoy Vamos a repasar esta y muchas
otras claves para entender este hombre a
esta figura vamos a decirlo claro este
año 2022 tiene dos protagonistas claro
Vladimir Putin y boladimir celestiky
tranquilos que el vídeo sobre lensky le
publicaremos también dentro de muy poco
y por cierto Aquí voy a daros un dato
curioso ambos políticos tienen el mismo
nombre es decir que bloodymir es
Vladimir en ucraniano si sois veterano
seguidores de visualpolitik ya sabéis
que aquí en este canal tenemos una
tradición navideña que cumplimos todos
los años los premios y los anti premios
visualpolitik es decir que dedicamos un
vídeo a los que nos parecen que han sido
los tres mejores políticos del año y
otro con los tres peores políticos del
año normalmente nos cuesta muchísimo
preparar esta lista y nos pasamos días
discutiendo y este año además teníamos
una obligación por un lado teníamos que
destacar a zelenski que por cierto ya
tiene un premio visualpolitik del año
pasado pero también a Putin un tipo del
que no esperá gran cosa pero es que ha
superado nuestras expectativas para mal
esto estaba tan claro que al final hemos
decidido dedicarles un vídeo entero a
cada uno y ya sé lo que estaréis
pensando muchos otro vídeo sobre Putin
pero si llevamos todo el año escuchando
a las barbaridades de este hombre a ver
qué más se puede contar de Putin que no
sepamos pues seamos claros desde el
punto de vista ético sí Putin se merece
todos los anti premios y condenas
posibles ahora bien hasta hace pocos
meses todos los analistas reconocían su
visión estratégica vamos que podía ser
malo pero no era tonto ahora bien
después de todos los errores que ha
cometido en Ucrania no está tan claro
que sea semejante Genio del mal Como
algunos podrían pensar y por eso en el
vídeo de hoy vamos a centrarnos en la
biografía de Putin quién es Vladimir
Putin qué legado político quiere dejar
en qué medida sus experiencias vitales
han influido en su ideología política
hoy vamos a responder a estas preguntas
pero antes vamos a ver un poco de
historia
[Música]
de la kgb al cielo de Moscú
desde que llegó el poder Vladimir Putin
ha querido hacerse ver como un hombre
fuerte capaz en el imaginario colectivo
incluso de cazar un tigre con sus
propias manos o de doblegar un oso en
una lucha muerte Pero y si os dijera que
este ex agente del kgb no era tan
importante ni tan imponente como lo es
hoy en día la realidad es que no fue
ninguna especie de James Bond ruso en
realidad se parecía más a un funcionario
de los que están en una oficina haciendo
números absolutamente lo opuesto al
clásico político mesiánico que hemos
conocido después Putin nació en el año
1952 en la ciudad más liberal de toda la
unión soviética leningrado que es lo que
hoy es San Petersburgo A diferencia de
zelansky Putin se crió en una familia
Obrera y aquí viene una de las grandes
claves de su vida su padre era un
convencido comunista y su madre una
ferviente cristiano ortodoxa tan
religiosa era esta mujer que decidió
bautizar a su hijo en secreto incluso
sin que lo supiera el padre En otras
palabras que su alma ya estaba dividida
desde su niñez y esto ha marcado la
ideología de Putin hasta nuestros días
de hecho atentos a una de sus citas más
recordadas quien no la desaparición de
la unión soviética no tiene corazón
quien quiera restaurarla no tiene
cerebro Vladimir Putin 20 de febrero año
2000 sin embargo durante su juventud
Putin fue todo un patriota de la unión
soviética por eso Tan pronto como
terminó sus estudios en 1975 ingresó en
la kgb por si alguien no lo sabe la kgb
era la agencia de inteligencia soviética
el equivalente a la Cia y aquí es donde
suele comenzar el mito de Putin como un
héroe de la nación comprometido con sus
compatriotas y con la madre Rusia
estoy seguro de que muchos de vosotros
habréis escuchado que Putin fue muy
importante en el servicio de
inteligencia soviético Y todos nos hemos
imaginado alguna vez a una especie de
James Bond versión comunista Pero la
realidad es bastante menos espectacular
en realidad la mayor parte del trabajo
de un espía tanto en la caja B como en
cualquier otra agencia de inteligencia
es trabajo de oficina de hecho Putin se
encargaba principalmente de reclutar a
los informantes le destinaron a las
oficinas de Alemania del este que por
Entonces era una colonia de La Unión
soviética y viviendo en Berlín este
Putin vivió uno de los acontecimientos
más importantes de la historia reciente
algo que le obligó a replantearse sus
convicciones comunistas en el año 1989
los alemanes derribaron el muro de
Berlín tras años más tarde Putin volvió
a su ciudad natal mientras el presidente
de La Unión soviética mijail gorbachov
anunciaba El Fin Del comunismo como os
podéis imaginar todo esto supuso un
shock para los valores que Putin había
defendido Durante los años de la kgb Y
eso explica que renunciar a su puesto y
se metiera en la política empezó
asesorando al primer alcalde elegido
democráticamente en San Petersburgo su
primer trabajo de hecho fue Buscar
inversores para la ciudad
el ascenso al poder de Putin comenzó
justamente aquí al lograr mantener a los
oligarcas bien atados así en 1998 se
hizo con El poder del servicio Federal
de seguridad la antigua kg por Entonces
ya era un gerifalte de un partido
político
[Música]
sin embargo el segundo shock ideológico
llegó en el año 1998 Y diréis qué pasó
ese año Pues fue cuando Putin perdió a
su madre si recordáis la madre de Putin
era una ferviente cristiana Pues bien en
su lecho de muerte le regaló un
crucifijo y por lo que dicen los
biógrafos desde entonces nunca se lo ha
quitado este fue el momento donde Putin
renovó su fe y creedme esto es algo
mucho más importante de lo que parece
Pero eso lo vamos a ver más adelante El
caso es que con su fe renovada en 1999
yelstein ya estaba allanando el camino
para la toma de poder de Putin y a
principios de ese año le nombró Primer
Ministro y más tarde presidente en
funciones
[Música]
tras la dimisión de yelsin y la
convocatoria de elecciones Putin se
convirtió en presidente de Rusia de
manera absoluta ganó las elecciones del
año 2000 con más de un 50% de los votos
y elsin le había dado al pueblo un nuevo
líder al que seguir y ya sé lo que os
estaréis preguntando muchos cómo es
posible que un tipo como Putin que
incluso mucha gente le tenía miedo
dentro del país llegó al poder Pues eso
explica por dos sencillas razones La
promesa de una economía mejor después de
la crisis de 1998 y su firmeza frente al
terrorismo cheno recordemos que
chechenia era un territorio turbulento
para Rusia con aspiraciones
independentistas que terminaron con una
dura confrontación militar con Moscú
Pues bien Putin iba a ser el hombre
fuerte y decidido que Rusia quería Putin
prometía Aires de renovación en el país
pero era consciente de que gran parte de
su población todavía echaba de menos a
la unión soviética y por eso restauró
con algunos cambios en la letra el himno
de la unión soviética como himno
nacional y utilizó la bandera de la
unión soviética para eventos militares
ahora entendéis mis queridos amigos de
visualpolitik porque en Ucrania todavía
se ven tan que rusos con banderas
soviéticas pero del simbolismo que ha
hecho realmente Putin En qué cree
exactamente Pues ahora mismo lo vamos a
ver
capitalismo a la Putin
si recordáis Putin estuvo destinado a la
Alemania comunista con el kgb hasta que
cayó el muro de Berlín vivían sus
propias carnes las ineficiencias de la
Administración soviética funcionarios
corruptos gente sin talento que llega al
poder por favor es políticos y una
espiral de errores que llevaron al
colapso final desde entonces Putin tiene
claro que el comunismo no funciona el
comunismo y el poder de los soviets no
hicieron de Rusia un país próspero con
una sociedad en desarrollo Dinámico y un
pueblo libre Vladimir Putin vamos que
computing estaba Claro que no habría una
vuelta al comunismo pero el sistema que
había heredado de Boris gelsing tampoco
es que fuera demasiado eficiente
Entonces qué creéis que hizo si sois
fieles seguidores de visualpolitik
seguro que ya lo habéis adivinado un
capitalismo a la Putin y como lo
construyó pues utilizando a unos viejos
conocidos del Canal los sylobiquís si
recordáis los silobiquís son políticos y
altos funcionarios del gobierno con una
larga carrera en los servicios de
seguridad del país por ejemplo
fueron sus antiguos compañeros de
trabajo y aquí quiero que hagamos una
reflexión interesante para Putin El
problema del comunismo no es la economía
centralizada sino los malos gestores es
decir que cuando yelsing intentó su
transición al capitalismo totalmente
fallida se rodeó de oligarcas con poca
formación y vamos a decirlo Claro en
muchos casos con adicciones de todo tipo
por eso la gran apuesta de Putin fue
sustituir a estos malos gestores por
gente con ideas firmes mano dura y buen
currículum eso es el principio básico de
lo que podríamos Llamar el capitalismo
de los lobiquis y diréis funcionó bien
este sistema Pues en principio parecería
que sí fijaos en esta gráfica
[Música]
desde que Putin llegó al poder en el año
2000 la economía rusa creció sin
interrupción hasta el año 2008 de hecho
los salarios de los rusos se duplicaron
seguro que la mayoría os imagináis Por
qué Exacto Rusia es una potencia
energética en un momento donde el gas y
el petróleo tenían precios altos Rusia
vivió una luna de miel la economía iba
viento en popa y incluso lograron
ajustar todas las cuentas del Estado
pero fuera como fuera el tiempo parecía
darle la razón a Putin su receta
económica no se basaba en crear y nuevas
instituciones fuertes sino en poner a
buenos gestores en los puestos de
decisión y diréis Pero esto es todo esto
es todo lo que podemos decir de la
ideología de Putin pues obviamente no
hay mucho más ahora mismo lo vamos a ver
[Música]
Europa y Asia Unidas
está claro que para entender a Putin no
hay que leer a Marx pero tampoco hay que
leer ni a Hayek ni Adam Smith sin
embargo Putin tiene sus referentes
ideológicos que son autores rusos
prácticamente desconocidos en occidente
intelectuales como ivani link o
Alexander duhigging y esto nos lleva a
hablar de una ideología de la que seguro
que muy pocos habréis oído hablar en
este canal el eurasianismo básicamente
el eurasianismo defiende la creación de
un bloque cultural entre Europa y Asia
en contra de lo que sería el bloque
ángulo americano por supuesto todo esto
se puede traducir en una frase
reestablecer el Imperio colonial ruso
pero para los euroasiáticos todo esto
tiene una justificación muchísimo más
profunda que siempre colonialismo y Cómo
se traduce esto a la política pues vamos
a verlo
[Música]
Putin sigue una especie de versión
actualizada de los cinco puntos que el
Primer Ministro ruso de 1993 jefgeni
primakov siguió el primero es la defensa
de la posición de Rusia como potencia
mundial y no solo regional el segundo lo
que se conoce como el pragmatismo
racional tercero la asociación con china
como piedra angular de la política
exterior rusa el cuarto la oposición a
cualquier expansión de la otan y los
vínculos con aquellos países que quieran
luchar contra la hegemonía de Estados
Unidos y el quinto que Rusia utilice su
poderío nuclear y su poder de veto en el
consejo de seguridad de las Naciones
Unidas
de hecho la versión actualizada de esta
ideología el neurasienismo que defienden
algunos autores como Alexander ducking y
muchos más ve a tres países específicos
que podrían ayudar a Rusia a liderar
este proyecto euroasiático Alemania para
controlar Europa Irán para estrechar
lazos con los Países Árabes y Japón para
controlar Asia y diréis como Japón y no
china Pues sí porque dooging y otros
muchos autores no se fían de las futuras
pretensiones e imperialistas de China al
menos Esta es la teoría paréntesis
Alexander duguines Quizás El intelectual
ruso más conocido fuera del país sin
embargo hay bastante debates sobre cómo
de importante su influencia dentro del
círculo de poder de Putin pero eso es
otra historia Lo cierto es que el
neurasimismo sí que es una ideología
fundamental para entender lo que es el
kremlin hoy en día y os preguntaréis Por
qué Putin quiere formar este bloque
euroasiático Pues bien si recordáis el
neuracianismo Quiere arrancar de Las
garras del Tío Sam la política del mundo
dicho de otra forma Putin defiende un
orden mundial multipolar en
contraposición a la hegemonía
indiscutible de los Estados Unidos y
Cuáles serían estos otros polos bien por
un lado eurasia bajo el mando ruso claro
china por el otro y Estados Unidos por
el otro vamos que la esencia del
eurocenismo se podría resumir en lo
siguiente Rusia debería recuperar el
estatus de Gran potencia y convertirse
en un centro de oposición al
unilateralismo estadounidense en la
política mundial en doctor en la
universidad de mármara Y cómo puede
recuperar este estatus Rusia por
supuesto uno de esos Pilares es un
ejército fuerte y eso explica la
modernización del ejército que se llevó
a cabo en la década de 2010
pero no solo eso porque para convertirse
en una potencia hegemónica Rusia
necesita poder blando y eso nos lleva a
la doctrina cara ganó Este término que
parece sacado de una película es uno de
los principales instrumentos de Putin
para justificar sus invasiones y diréis
en qué consiste pues muy simple en hacer
de Rusia la protectora de todas las
personas étnicamente rusas que viven en
los países de alrededor incluso Aunque
tengan otra nacionalidad esto puede
suponer incluso dar pasaporte rusos a
las poblaciones de territorios de otros
países y así es como luego se puede
justificar la intervención del ejército
en teoría están defendiendo a sus
compatriotas y por eso esto se conoce
también como política de los
compatriotas ya hemos visto esta
política en las regiones de Ucrania que
supuestamente votaron por formar parte
de Rusia y diréis es Putin líder
euroasiático perfecto ni muchísimo menos
en política ya sabéis que una cosa es la
teoría y otra la práctica por ejemplo
durante la Guerra de Afganistán Putin
permitió que Estados Unidos estableciera
bases militares en la central esto le
hizo ganar todo tipo de críticas entre
la línea dura del eurasianismo sin
embargo aunque no el líder euroasiático
perfecto Es realmente el único en la
región ahora mismo su objetivo sigue
siendo el mismo que Estados Unidos no
tenga Tanto poder y que Rusia
restablezca su honor pero para eso
necesita algo más que debilitar al Tío
Sam necesita crear una identidad
euroasiática y diréis cómo se puede
hacer eso pues atentos
[Música]
in Putin we Trust
[Aplausos]
recordáis que Putin se reafirmó en la
ortodoxa a la muerte de su madre pues
esto no es solo una anécdota la llegada
de Putin al poder trajo un cambio
radical en la manera en la que se
trataba la religión en Rusia de hecho su
Pilar maestro para la identidad de
euroasiática es nada más y nada menos
que la iglesia ortodoxa para vos a
pensar por un momento la unión soviética
era un estado ateo es decir que la
religión estaba perseguida incluida la
ortodoxa sin embargo Aunque la unión
soviética aplastase a la religión en su
territorio No mataron la fe de hecho hoy
más del 70% de la población de Rusia se
considera cristiana ortodoxa y por eso
la iglesia ortodoxa es una figura clave
para este proyecto euroasiático a fin de
cuentas si quieres invadir países
Necesitas algo más que armas también
necesitas construir una identidad
nacional y para eso la religión es
fundamental y diréis pero todo esto Cómo
se traduce en políticas reales
Pues bien una de las primeras políticas
de Putin fue bajar los impuestos a la
iglesia ortodoxa a diferencia de muchos
otros países en Rusia las iglesias no
están exentas de pagar impuestos Pero
además en 2010 el kremlin devolvió todas
las propiedades que los comunistas
habían incautado a los religiosos no
solo eso Putin ha permitido que la
iglesia obtenga grandes beneficios de
las empresas energéticas y todo esto ha
supuesto una enorme inyección de capital
para los pobres ortodoxos gracias a esto
han podido construir más de 23.000
nuevas Iglesias en otras palabras que
mientras el resto de Europa van en una
dirección cada vez más secular Rusia va
en la dirección opuesta pero no solo
hablamos de dinero también Hablamos de
cultura por ejemplo en 2012 se introdujo
la asignatura de ortodoxia en todas las
escuelas públicas de Rusia y en 2016 se
introdujo la ley yarobaya que permite al
Estado reprimir a las comunidades
religiosas minoritarias Como por ejemplo
la protestante para que no evangelizaran
a los rusos y diréis que le ha dado
cambio la iglesia ortodoxa pues lo
habéis adivinado un apoyo incondicional
en todas las campañas de expansión rusas
en 2014 cuando Rusia apoyó a los secesi
de la parte este de Ucrania en el
donbash la iglesia sirvió como un
aparato de propaganda masiva en todas
las iglesias ortodoxas se defendían los
intereses del kremlin y esta lealtad
llega hasta nuestros días atentos el
patriarca kiril llama a los rusos a la
movilización espiritual agencia F 27 de
septiembre de 2022 de hecho el patriarca
de la iglesia ortodoxa rusa ha llegado a
decir que la guerra purificaría el alma
de todo aquel que cayera en combate
fijaos la iglesia es consciente de que
si alguien muere en el cumplimiento del
deber militar Entonces indudablemente se
sacrifica por los demás este sacrificio
lava todos los pecados que una persona
ha cometido patriarca quiril y la
pregunta es hasta qué punto Vladimir
Putin está consiguiendo este sueño
euroasiático
pues tenemos que reconocer que hasta
este año 2022 estaba dando pasos muy
importantes en esta dirección por
ejemplo en 2014 culminó uno de los
proyectos clave del euracianismo la
unión económica euroasiática esta Unión
junta solamente a cinco países Rusia por
supuesto Bielorrusia kazajistán
kirguistán y Armenia el año pasado le
dedicamos un vídeo entero a esta Unión
que podría ser algo así como un intento
de hacer una versión rusa de la Unión
Europea con libertad de movimiento para
personas capitales y bienes entre estos
cinco países el problema El problema es
que la Guerra de Ucrania ha puesto todo
esto en entredicho uno de los países más
importantes de esta Unión es kazajistán
que cada vez se aleja más de la órbita
rusa Pero de eso ya hemos hablado largo
y tendido en otros vídeos y en más que
vendrán el año que viene pero ahora la
pregunta es para vosotros será la Guerra
de Ucrania un golpe definitivo para el
proyecto euroasiático de Putin Y si
ganara la guerra eso supondría un
impulso no temerían sus socios
euroasiáticos a la madre Rusia si no
estuvieran de acuerdo con Putin podéis
dejarme vuestra respuesta en los
comentarios y como siempre no olvidéis
Que aquí en visualpolitik sacamos vídeos
nuevos Todas las semanas así que
suscribiros a este canal y dadle a la
campanita para no ninguna de nuestras
actualizaciones si os ha gustado este
vídeo dadle a like y nos vemos en el
próximo un saludo y hasta pronto
[Música]